hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the history of the
British Ministry of magic of course
there are a lot of things that took
place there throughout the Harry Potter
series but today we'll be focusing on
what happened prior to our dear boy
Harry showing up on the Wizarding scene
so without further Ado let's get started
shall we what is the ministry of magic
formed in 1707 the British Ministry of
magic is the main governing body of the
magical community of the United Kingdom
and Ireland it was created to preserve
magical law within Great Britain and
represent these countries to the larger
Wizarding World Its formation came as a
direct result of the previously created
Wizards Council prior to 1707 the
Wizards Council was the longest serving
though not the only body to govern the
magical community in Britain after the
imposition of the international attitude
of secrecy in 1692 however the Wizarding
Community needed a more highly
structured organized and more complex
governing structure than they had
hitherto used to support regulate and
communicate with a community in hiding
this of course led to what is now known
as the ministry of magic employees of
the ministry are largely unelected with
the exception of the minister who is
voted in by Great Britain's Wizarding
Community as seen in the Fantastic
Beasts films many other countries in the
Wizarding World have their own
ministries of Magic including France
Germany and Bulgaria the United States
also has a magical governing body but as
we learned in Fantastic Beasts and Where
to Find Them their government is called
the magical Congress of the United
States of America or makusa the location
of the ministry and how to access it the
headquarters for the British Ministry of
magic is located well beneath his
Majesty's treasury building in central
London deep underground witches and
wizards employed by the ministry can
enter by flu Network or Apparition
however during Voldemort's rise to power
in the 1990s employees of lower rank
were forced to enter the ministry by way
of a toilet Network visitors the
ministry can access the building from
above ground through a nearby
disconnected red telephone box by
dialing the word magic Ministry events
of the 18th century as mentioned earlier
the British Ministry of magic was
founded the beginning of the 18th
century in 1707 upon its establishment
the former Chief Warlock the wizen gamut
eulogamp assumed the role the first ever
Minister for magic in Great Britain for
those of you who may not recall the
wizard gamut is Britain's Wizarding high
court of law on Parliament which
predates the ministry in any case during
Minister Camp's term he founded the
department of magical law enforcement
meaning that this department has existed
tested since the early 18th century it
was also during this time that the
ministry guided its citizens through the
Wizarding world's adjustment to the
international statute of secrecy of
1692. the years to follow were formative
in the ministry's foundational
operations for example in 1717 the
ministry officially classified the
imperius cruciatus and Ivana cadaver
curses as the unforgivable curses and
then sometime during the next Minister
for Magic's term between 1718 and 1726
Azkaban was made into the official
Wizarding prison this idea came from
Damocles Rao the minister at the time
who chose Azkaban as the location for
the jail over the remote hebridian
island despite much protest from The
Wizarding Community the next Minister
for magic Perseus Parkinson attempted to
pass a bill which would have made it
illegal to marry Muggles a law which as
we know was in forced in the United
States however the bill never passed in
the UK and Parkinson was voted out soon
after
sometime between 1747 and 1752 the
ministry faced a goblin and a werewolf
Rebellion which apparently was rather
mismanaged by the minister at the time
Albert Bude quite unfortunately his
successor basil Flack did little better
as he was only in office for a mere two
months before being removed from the
position
black is the shortest serving minister
to ever hold the position within the
ministry unfortunately the ministry was
able to quell a number of revolts after
this time during the rule of Hephaestus
Gaul the goal also led the ministry's
renovation of Azkaban prisons facilities
in 1782 the ministry secretly convened
with the Mughal government to support
the prime minister at the time lord
Frederick North with King George III's
ailing mental health unfortunately this
connection only served to call Lord
North's sanity into question for his
rumored belief in Wizards
1798 then saw the induction of the
ministry's first female Minister for
magic Artemisia Lufkin during her 13
years in office she established the
department of international magical
cooperation and held the Quidditch World
Cup for the first time in Britain 19th
century ministers and events following
lufkin's time in office grogan's dump
served as Minister from 1811 to 1819 and
led the ministry's establishment of the
Department of magical games and sports
then under the rule of autoline gamble
sometime between 18 27 in 1835 the
ministry saw the creation of multiple
committees whose purpose was to
investigate muckles and their
intelligence these Ministry committees
uncovered that many Muggles were indeed
smarter than the Wizarding Community had
previously believed the department of
mysteries was almost closed down
sometime between 1835 and 1841. due to
the reactionary nature the minister of
the time rodolfus Le strange however
Lestrange was outed from office before
he could officially instate the closure
the next sitting Minister will tencia
milifet introduced more legislation to
the ministry between 1841 and 1849 than
any other witch or wizard who held the
possession evidently much of what the
ministry pushed through was indeed
useful however a bit of it was rather
worrisome and is likely what led to the
end of miliford's term in office
during Queen Victoria's reign of England
the Monarch unknowingly befriended witch
and Minister for magic Evangeline
orpington this friendship may have been
what motivated orpington to allegedly
get the ministry involved in the Crimean
War an act which would have been quite
illegal at the time then between the
years of 1858 and 1865 the ministry
experienced a welcome period of Peace
under the governance of Minister for
magic do called mcphail immediately
following Fell's term the ministry then
saw its longest ever serving Minister
one Varys spout Hall spavin who served
for nearly 40 years from 1865 to 1903.
spavin was 147 when he finally left
office at which point he'd survived an
assassination attempt from a centaur and
attended Queen Victoria's funeral during
spavin's term the ministry once again
faced the rise of a goblin rebellion in
the late 1800s led by a goblin named
Rand Rock 20th century ministers and
events during the muggle's first world
war the ministry passed emergency
legislation which made it illegal for
The Wizarding community in Britain to
involve themselves in the Warfare this
was done under Minister Archer evermond
who feared participating in the Great
War would risk mass infractions of the
international statute of secrecy this
legislation was largely ignored with
thousands of witches and wishes defying
the law in order to help their local
neighbors the ministry was then wildly
unprepared to meet the growing threat of
Gaelic Grindelwald in the 1920s and 30s
due to the minister at the time Hector
Foley not taking grindelwald's rise to
power seriously as a result the ministry
ousted fully to pay for his insufficient
action and ineptitude while Winston
Churchill was in office however the
ministry enjoyed a good working
relationship with the Mughal Parliament
primarily thanks to the minister for
magic between 1939 and 90 1948 Leonard
Spencer moon in large contrast about a
decade later the minister for magic
between 1959 and 1962 Ignatius tuft
attempted to Institute a controversial
dementor breeding program fortunately
the ministry forced Taft out of office
before he was able to turn this
terrifying program into a reality
in 1962 nearly 250 years after its
formation the ministry of magic inducted
its first ever muggle-born Minister for
magic knobby Leach his appointment as
Minister caused many pure blood ministry
employees to resign in protest and in
the late 1960s while Eugenia Jenkins was
in office the ministry dealt with the
bout of pure blood riots which took
place during squib rights marches then
in response to Lord Voldemort's first
rise to power in the 1970s the ministry
attempted to bolster its protection
against the dark wizard with efforts
such as placing more Dementors around
Azkaban fortunately Voldemort's first
defeat by Harry Potter occurred in 1981
making additional security unnecessary
the dark lost his appearance led to a
mass celebration among Wizarding
community in Britain these celebrations
caused a number of breaches against the
international statute of secrecy leaving
the ministry to defend the actions of
its citizens against the international
Confederation of wizards apparently the
minister for magic at the time Millicent
bagnold responded with the now Infamous
statement of I assert our inalienable
right to party it's known by many Among
The Wizarding community that the
ministry wanted to Alba Dumbledore to
assume the position of British Minister
for magic after bagnall's retirement in
1990 but of course he turned it down and
the job went instead to Cornelius Finch
who was the minister in power the start
of the Harry Potter series
much of what took place at the ministry
after Harry Potter's arrival at Hogwarts
you likely know well but as a brief
recap of events in 1996 the ministry of
magic was breached by Death Eaters and
Hogwarts students alike including Harry
and his friends this bridge led to what
would become known as the battle of the
Department of mysteries sometimes also
referred to as the battle of the
ministry of magic Rufus scrimger was the
minister to serve after fudge was forced
out of office due to his refusal to
believe that Voldemort had returned
tragically scrimja was then murdered by
the dark lord himself while still in
office bias thickness then served for
only a year operating under duress of
the imperious curse his term has
therefore been omitted from most
official Ministry records
since the second defeat of Lord
Voldemort the ministry has experienced a
time of relative peace with Kingsley
shacklebolt serving until 1998 and
Hermione Granger taking over in 2019 and
with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think did I
miss anything about the British
ministry's history please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live